the PlayStation 4 had a strong 2015 two
years into its lifecycle it remains
ahead of its competitors in terms of
sales and boasts an impressive library
spanning every genre within our
embarrassment of riches here are the
games GameSpot calls the best of the
best PlayStation 4 hit the ground
running in 2015 with blood-borne our
highest voted exclusive for the console
it hit the sweet spot for many souls
fans and reeled in those who had never
played from software's dark fantasy
games drenched in gore and colored by
darkness blood-borne stole our time with
a comfortable and accessible combat
system a never-ending stream of
challenging combat encounters and an
expertly crafted narrative that
unraveled slowly and suddenly a home -
yeah
we're always spurred on by the bits of
lore we find always eager to see what's
lurking behind every corner always
pushing ahead despite the constant
threat just one more gathering of blood
echoes just one more attempt at a boss
we've been salivating for fallout 4 is
post-apocalyptic world since rumours
first spread of its existence and once
it was in our hands it did not
disappoint the wasteland is dreary
enriched with thrifty traders and
hideous foes you help or hinder other
wastelanders kill death claws and other
gruesome beasts for its supplies meet
survivors and generally work your way to
becoming the wasteland Savior it's a
rollercoaster of an experience made even
more enjoyable by deep crafting and
settlement building systems that allow
you to leave your own personal mark on
the wasteland it's easy to get lost
literally and fallout 4 is dilapidated
irradiated version of Boston but fallout
4 isn't the only all-consuming
open-world adventure on ps4 this year
The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt dropped you into
a lush vibrant fantasy land into the
shoes of infamous monster hunter Geralt
of Rivia Geralt mission is personal in
his story poignant as are the side
quests and intertwined plot lines
throughout the game The Witcher threes
world is just beautiful and so are its
stories romance and companions resolving
other's heartbreak and searching for and
protecting your loved ones are how
you'll spend your time wild hence world
has also been supported by an excellent
mansion hearts of stone the perfect
addition for those of us who want more
after completing every inch of content
in the main game in this we acknowledge
The Witcher 3 as one of the best of the
best on PlayStation 4 unearthing the
mysteries and lore of Metal Gear Solid 5
the phantom pain provided one of our
favorite things to do this year even if
you know nothing of Metal Gear the
phantom pain story of sacrifice and loss
is a powerful one and forms the
foundation of its complex yet engaging
world whether you're running into combat
with d-dog or quiet just spending some
time building up mother base or folding
animals there's never a dull moment
adding to the potency to paint and paint
is that it's a send-off for Metal Gear
creator Hideo Kojima it is evident that
his heart and soul went into this game
efforts have been worth it
the phantom pain leaves a lasting
impression on us that we won't be quick
to forget rounding up ps4 is best is
indeed darling rocket League it came
seemingly out of nowhere rocket league
launched with very little PR hype or
fanfare on its initial release and yet
without marketing guidance players
discovered in some countless hours into
matches something about using cars to
boot giant balls around a soccer field
is addicting and we constantly feel
challenged to do better execute better
tricks and master the game and a
plethora of small flourishes give rocket
league an undeniable charm putting a hat
on the car making rainbows come out of
your exhaust pipe or having the flag of
your country wobbling around as you tear
across the field it's the game of choice
for our staffs multiplayer sessions we
love rocket leagues perfect little
package because it connects us with each
other in meaningful challenges when a
team comes together for that one magical
moment where you carry a ball across an
area bouncing between teammates and off
the ceiling and walls then into the net
it's undeniably satisfying it takes
common videogame elements and matches
them together into something totally
tantalizing the news
to those who haven't purchased a ps4 yet
with a best of list like this one it's
difficult to say that the purchase isn't
worth it and to those who already have
one we hope you like us get the chance
to enjoy these games as much as we do
you